hello guys welcome back to jaegers in
today's video we'll be going through the
story of historia rhys the worst girl
who ever lived his story was born as the
illegitimate and unrecognized daughter
of rod reese head of the reese family
and the true monarchs of the walls her
mother alma was the servant in his
household who later became his mistress
and confidant his story was then raised
on a farm which was owned and
administered by the reese family her
mother was deliberately distant from her
spending much of her time reading or
leaving the estate at night via
carriages she never participated in work
around the estate it appeared to have
some other source of income adding to
her isolation the other children outside
the estate would throw rocks at her and
she was not allowed to leave however her
half-sister freda reese who would often
visit her in secret taught historia how
to read and further encouraged her
personal development in the hopes of
becoming a kind girl that everyone would
love she would chide historia for not
being more ladylike but would become
more distressed when the girl spoke of
her as an ideal role model of a proper
lady after every meeting frida would
modify historia's memories using the
power of the founding titan she
possessed and historia would forget many
of these interactions and her existence
save for when these memories were
subconsciously accessed during dreams
however his story would forget about
these dreams when she awoke growing up
she began to read every book she could
get her hands on including ones that
depicted a typical relationship between
a mother and her child causing historia
to question her own relationship with
her mother and desiring to understand
what it was like to have meaningful
physical contact with her mother this
led to an attempt to hug her mother
resulting in her being violently slapped
away causing her mother to openly lament
that she did not have the bravery to
kill historia when she was born though
bruised and bloody historia felt
happiness because it was the first time
she'd ever been spoken to by her mother
after this incident she would not see
nor interact with her mother again for
several years days after the fall of
walmaria rodris comes to the estate with
her mother to see hystoria and to take
her to the reece household properly it
is assured that his story would thus be
recognized as a child and heir to the
reese family as they attempt to evacuate
they are surrounded by unmarked soldiers
of the first interior squad of the
military police brigade who are looking
to remove the blots on the reece family
name they confront rod over the identity
of historia and her mother rod in turn
denies any relation to them one of the
soldiers kenny ackerman restrains alma
and kills her as she desperately
attempts to deny being historia's mother
and her existence thereof her last
testament before having her throat cut
is to look at her daughter coldly and
say that she wishes she had never given
birth to her the soldiers then prepare
to kill historia as well but rod
intercepts their efforts by offering an
alternative arrangement that if she were
to disappear from the reece household
assume a new name and identity before
enlisting as a soldier that would mean
they would not need to kill her the
soldiers agree with this and rod gives
her the new name of crystal lens
due to the influence of fritoris
historia is able to use a persona that
she had created for herself that was to
be in all things selfless and kind to
those around her it is this persona that
she uses when entering the military in
her innermost self however she is a
melancholy empty shell of a girl
uncertain of her true nature and
personality and of her purpose and
meaning in the world her first night as
a trainee his story sneaks out after
eating dinner to bring a loaf of bread
and some water to sasha blouse as she is
finishing her punishment for eating food
during the trainee's initiation another
trainee ymir approaches the two wanting
to know why historia is helping sasha
and historia claims that she just wants
to be helpful to her fellow soldiers
ymir helps the story return sasha to her
bunk but makes it clear that she will
use the event to take advantage of sasha
at a later time during the training
historians spending time with yumir and
sasha when yamir confronts sasha about
speaking in an overly polite tone rather
than her home's dialect when yamir
begins to criticize her for it historia
scolds her and claims that sasha should
speak however she wants to at some point
during training the trainees of the
104th training corps complete a
snowstorm training exercise arriving at
the base of the foot of a mountain after
her fellow trainee dazz loses
consciousness during the exercise his
story elects to try to pull his body
along on a cot despite yamir's protests
ymir argues that they will only survive
if they abandon daz and head for the
base together but historia insists that
they could all survive if yamir goes
ahead of her noticing that historia has
not asked for help during their entire
course ymir deduces his story has no
intention of saving dez nor herself and
that she is using their situation as an
excuse to search for her own heroic end
yamir reveals that she is aware of
historia's true past having heard
officials from the church of the walls
discussing her existence his story asks
if ymir joined the training car in order
to find her and yamir proposes that it
might be due to her own past being
similar his story asks if yamir
originally wanted to befriend her but
ymir said that they are nothing alike
ezymir kept her old name after starting
a new life because abandoning her name
would be to admit defeat by living for
herself she robbed her enemies of their
power ymir scolds cystoria for looking
for death rather than directing her
feelings towards her enemies and
historia says that there's no longer any
way for all three of them to survive
their mission ymir leads historia to a
cliff overlooking the base at the foot
of the mountain and proposes tossing
dazz over the edge so that she and
historia could make it to the base alive
while daz could be searched for later
when historia objects ymir takes matters
into her own hands and throws her aside
into a snow bank when his story escapes
from the snow and returns to the cliff
ymir and daz are nowhere to be found
when his story arrives at the base she
spots a mirror outside the base she asks
about daz and dimir shows her the dez
was safe indoors upon looking at the
cliff from the ground historia sees that
such a descent would be impossible
without a rope ymir decides to reveal
the hystoria how she saved as but only
if she promises to live by her true name
when her secret eventually becomes known
to everyone upon her subsequent training
and graduation she is ranked as 10th of
the 104th a rank below sasha blouse
during the battle of drost's district
historia squad discovers armin in a
catatonic state following the death of
his squad mates when kanye and ymir get
into a fight over whether or not to
leave him historia breaks them up saying
that the deaths of their comrades have
upset them when armin suddenly leaves
historia squad continues to move forward
through trost later while awaiting
orders with her fellow trainees astoria
listens as connie gives an account of
how she and the other trainees managed
to resupply in the military headquarters
in the aftermath of the battle of
drost's district she reports her
vertical maneuvering equipment to the
military police brigade for inspection
as a part of the investigation over the
deaths of two captured titans presumed
to have been killed by a soldier using
vertical maneuvering equipment despite
her fears facing the titans in combat
again she volunteers to become a member
of the survey corps something she later
says is a decision made by her innermost
self and that she herself does not
understand the reasons behind it during
her first expedition out of the walls
historia is given control of an extra
horse in addition to her own she comes
across gene kerstein's horse and leads
it back to him after observing his
emergency smoke signal upon returning
jean's horse she accompanies him reiner
braun and armand arler to a nearby titan
forest telling them that she is relieved
that they are still alive she is seen to
be holding her position on the tree line
with her fellow soldiers baiting the
titans and preventing them from entering
the forest while the survey corps
attempt to capture the female titan
historia is among the survey corps
recruits that are investigated by mike
zacharias under suspicion of being one
of annie's accomplices the investigation
is halted when nanobot reports that
walbrose has been breached the soldiers
are ordered to go on horseback and
evacuate the local citizens nearby
historia and emir are placed underneath
command for the mission both the
recruits are devoid of the vertical
equipment indimir initially voices her
aversion to the idea of entering titan
territory unarmed though historia is
willing to help out their team
eventually meets up with gelgar's team
and they're shocked to learn that
neither team has been able to find a
breach unable to double back and search
again due to nightfall the two teams
take refuge of a nearby castle to rest
for the night in the middle of the night
the castle comes under attack from the
titans as the four soldiers that are
equipped for the battle engage the
titans outside the recruits try to
barricade the entrance to the castle so
that none of the smaller titans can get
in but find that the castle has already
been infiltrated reiner is attacked and
historia ymir and connie roll a nearby
cannon into it knocking it away from
rhino another titan enters the tower
which reiner manages to push out of a
window getting himself hurt in the
process the recruits flee further up
into the castle's tower and dystoria
uses a strip of her skirt to bandage
reiner's wound the recruits retreat to
the top of the tower where they watch as
the four scout soldiers are
systematically killed by the attacking
titans historia tries throwing rocks at
the titans to stop them declaring that
she's willing to fight to the death
against them but yamir calls her out for
trying to use her superior's death as a
reason to die taking a knife from connie
yamir reminds her of the promise they
made on the night they got stranded in
the woods with daz and advises her to
live her life with pride before historia
can stop her ymir jumps off the tower
and uses the knife to transform herself
into a titan as historia and the rest of
the trainees watching her fighting
against the group of titans nearly
falling off the tower when emir
transformed reiner questioned her if she
knew about it when the trainees question
whose side yamir is on his story
remembers some events about her and
along with the others watching yamir's
attempt to fight the other titans and
came to the conclusion that she is
fighting to protect everyone she begins
to cheer for ymir telling her not to die
and to break down the tower and
celebrates when yamir does so she along
with the others ride on her back and
land on the ground safely as ymir starts
getting eaten by titans historia tries
to make her way to ymir but is stopped
by a titan which is swiftly killed by a
newly arrived mikasa as everyone watches
in disbelief at ymir's wounds and the
truth historia reveals her true name to
ymir back on top of wall rose historia
pleads with hanji zoe to go easy on ymir
while she knew that her friend was wrong
in hiding information they could have
been useful to the survey corps she
understood she did it to protect her
comrades hanji agrees with historia
stating that any information emir has
will be important for humanity after
reiner and bertolt reveal themselves to
be titans historian watches in horror as
reiner in his armored titan form grabs
aaron while richolt snatches ymir in his
colossus titan form during the battle
she is assigned to provide care for the
wounded she insists that ymir is still
alive and begs the other soldiers to
search for her she joins the rescue
mission against darman's advice the team
eventually manages to catch up with
rainer and bertolt but are unaware that
emir has been convinced to ally with
them in exchange for his story to safety
when yamir appears in her titan form
historia rushes to greet her and is
swiftly ensnared by ymir's mouth so the
warriors could kidnap her as the titans
flee from the military ymir finally
spits around and partially emerges from
her titan form so they can speak
historia initially believes that ymir is
being forced to cooperate with the
traitors and begs to be released so they
can escape however bertolt points out
that emir is not being forced to work
with them at this point ymir apparently
breaks down telling her that she intends
to use historia's status as the heir of
the rhys family begging historia to
cooperate in response historia smiles
and states that she will always be on
ymir's side when mikasa arrives into
taximir historia quickly steps forward
to stop the fight she pleads with her to
spare you mirror and refuses to back
down even when mikasa threatens her it
is only when mikasa makes it clear that
she will not spare anyone who gets in
her way the destroyer relents and
toximir out of fighting any further
before the conflict is resolved irwin
smith charges at the armored titan with
a horde of titans behind him his story
is nearly grabbed by titan until ymir
rescues her historia kills the titan in
the conflict the first on her record and
connie attempts to rescue her while the
military retreats historia rejects his
help saying that she must stay with ymir
if he mirrors to survive historia
returns to ymir letting her know that
her presence gives her the courage to
fight when aaron unleashes the
coordinate in the midst of the battle
drawing all mindless titans to his will
ymir chooses to leave with reiner and
retolt his story retreats with the
military reaching out to ymir as they
part ways indefinitely shortly afterward
his story is relocated with the new
special operations squad to an
undisclosed location on her first day
with the new squad historia reveals her
pass to her comrades the special
operations squad leaves from their
hideout on irwin's orders to rendezvous
and drost district but rather than going
into town historia hides with aaron in
an undisclosed location while armin and
jean act as a respective doubles levi
and hanji discover that the reese family
is the true royal family and irwin plans
to place astoria on the throne the
interior squad brings historia and aaron
through stoha's district and coffins on
their way to their destination where
historia reunites with rod reese who
apologizes for everything in the
underground caverns beneath the chapel
built by her family historia tells the
chained aaron that everything will be
alright explaining that rod has always
been an ally of humanity and had no
choice but to deal with minister nick
the reeves company and the survey corps
rod has himself and historia place their
hands on aaron to trigger grisha
yeager's memories so aaron will remember
his father's sin as a result of touching
aaron his story recovers the erased
memories of her beloved half-sister
frida she wants to thank her for being
there for her but rad explains that
freda was killed by aaron's father along
with the rest of rod's family because
grisha wanted the titan power that
resided inside her rod brings out a
satchel revealing a needle and serum and
tells the story that the frida is not
really dead since her memories live on
she can still meet her sister rod
explains how a special titan erected the
three walls and altered humanity's
memories only frida knew the truth about
how this world came to be having
devoured her uncle yuri and gained his
memories along with his powers of the
titans frida could have revealed the
truth to the world but did not which was
proof that she had inherited the
philosophy of the first ruler of the
walls rod tells historia that if frida
had lived she could have prevented their
current situation the breached walls the
civil war all the human lives that have
been lost this would not end as long as
aaron holds her stolen power because it
can only be truly used by a member of
the reese family kenny interrupts the
conversation to express his
disappointment in the bloodline
requirement by grabbing rod and shoving
his gun into his face historia pushes
kenny's weapon out of the way and
demands that he release her father kenny
spells it out for her that rod intends
to turn her into a titan so she can eat
aaron defiant historia asks what is so
sad about becoming a titan and saving
humanity she will eat aaron inherit the
history of the world and then
exterminate the titans kenny reminds her
that she was an unwanted child rod only
saved her because he needs her blood not
because he cares about her she watches
visibly upset as kenny jams a knife into
rod's mouth while telling her that rod
only cares about himself rod tries to
explain and pleads with historia not to
trust anyone else disgusted kennely
finally leaves him alone and walks over
to aaron he cuts aaron's forehead to
injure him and tells the story that they
can both fight to the death as titans
panicked rod gives the story a syringe
so she can change it to a titan before
aaron has a chance to escape his
restraints she takes the syringe but
notices that aaron is not transforming
when she asks why he expresses regret
for all the deaths that happen because
of him and his father and asks historia
to eat him to save humanity he says he
did not need to happen causing historia
to remember her unwanted childhood and
the day that aaron called her normal as
historia pushes the needle into her arm
she recalls her time with frida and with
ymir she asked her father why her sister
did not fight no one in the reese family
ever got rid of the titans or freed
humanity even though they had the power
she remembers how frieda would sometimes
act possessed and call everyone sinners
historia asks if that is because frida
inherited the first king's ideology and
rod confirms it saying that the first
king believed that having the titans
rule humanity was the true path to peace
historia smashes the syringe on the
floor rejecting her father's wishes she
throws him over her shoulder and takes
his satchel before running over to aaron
she uses the keys to start freeing aaron
and tells him that they are going to
escape he protests asking to be eaten
but historia cracks him on the head and
tells him to shut up in her opinion
humanity is the problem she pulls away
one of the chains around aaron and says
that she will let him get away before
she destroys everything even when rod
transforms into a titan after licking
the contents of the broken syringe
historia refuses to leave aaron she
tells him that even if she is humanity's
enemy she is erin's friend and when she
sees someone crying because no one needs
them she wants to tell them that that is
not true she opens another shackle
before being blown back from the winds
generated by rod's transformation but
mikasa catches her the rest of squad
levi appears to take over aaron's rescue
however the group is trapped in a
collapsing cavern aaron apologizes for
being useless but his story asks him if
he really wants to wait there until they
get burned or crushed to death simply
because the two of them are enemies of
humanity aaron gets up and grabs a
bottle labeled armor that has fallen out
of rod's satchel and breaks it between
his teeth as he transforms into a titan
this allows him to harden his tighten
body and create pillar-like structures
that support the collapsing cavern
without disappearing even after he is
extracted historia climbs out through
the open ceiling along with the rest of
the squad and they follow rodrice's
titan on wagon and horseback aaron
suggests allowing himself to be eaten
again since rod reese has the right
bloodline but his story argues against
it the rhys family has tried to undo the
first king's brainwashing for decades
and as soon as rad gets the power he can
erase everyone's memories again she
tells aaron that this may actually be
humanity's best hope because the
progenitor titan has been taken away
from the people who have such a terrible
idea about what makes peace hanji agrees
with astoria and asks if she is certain
of her choice they cannot restrain the
titan of rod's size so they will have to
kill her father historia thinks about
reuniting with rod and apologizes to
aaron because she really was going to
kill him back at the cavern not for
humanity's sake but because she did not
want her father to hate her now she
realizes it is time to say goodbye the
group reunites with irwin and falls back
to orvid district to prepare for the
titan's arrival rod approaches the wall
and the garrison begins shooting a
cannon barrage to stop him historia
helps hanji and the other soldiers put
together a web of rope around several
stacks of gunpowder barrels erwin
reminds her that she will be queen if
they survive this so it is a problem for
her to be on the front lines historia
asks him if the people are so naive that
they would obey a ruler in name only she
has given herself her own mission to
carry out and that is why she is here
historia tells everyone that once the
titan is dead he should say that she was
the one who finished it off that way the
situation inside the walls would
stabilize and people will come together
behind her when rod reaches the wall
aaron transforms into a titan and hurls
the web of barrels into the open mouth
of rod's titan the gunpowder barrels
ignite blowing off large chunks of the
titan's head and torso the survey core
use vertical maneuvering equipment to
attack the flying pieces in hopes of
cutting the nape before the titan can
regenerate historia cuts through a piece
of the titan and sees memories of a
young rod jailed while he demands
explanations from his father for not
killing the titans rod trying to find
solace in alma and of yuri and frida
expressing their belief that inheriting
their titan would not change them rod's
titan explodes and historia lands on a
padded cart as she regains consciousness
she finds herself surrounded by
surprised citizens who ask if she is the
one who finished off the titan they
cannot identify her military posting
since she is not wearing her uniform she
is initially uncertain if this is truly
her own decision but she stands up and
tells them that she is historia rhys the
true ruler of the walls historia is
grounded as the new queen before a large
and enthusiastic crowd people remember
seeing her protect them from the titan
and admire her for stopping her father
after the ceremony she and her friends
find levi so she can punch him in
retaliation for his bullying like demo
reeves suggested she shocks levi and to
her surprise he smiles and thanks
everyone two months later historia has
started running a farm where she can
bring orphans and other people in need
using her family's budget and assets
ceased from politicians the monarchy is
largely for show but despite that people
think well of her she rubs her friends
from squad levi into helping her with
the chores much to their dismay while
they are there she talks to aaron about
his hardening experiments in preparation
for recovering walmaria and he admits
that they need to hurry if they are to
do so before reiner and bertolt return
she asks if erin wants to kill them and
darren says that he has to she looks at
the farm and tells aaron that she cannot
regret turning down the first king's
power historia believes that what they
are doing here is right aaron expresses
his admiration for her considering that
she was ready to doom humanity when they
were back in the cave and she sputters
that she just got carried away before
they can talk any further mikasa
interrupts them and takes away the load
aaron is carrying ending the
conversation return to shigun china arc
after the operation she's given yamir's
letter she reads it and learns about
ymir's past after she finishes reading
the letter she calls him you're an idiot
and begins to cry at that moment she is
visited by aaron mikasa and armin she
remarks to them that she is glad the
three of them have barely changed
despite all that has happened to them
historia sits at the head of the
military meeting where it would be
decided how to proceed after the events
of chicago despite being queen historia
merely oversees the meeting until its
conclusion where she decides that the
military will reveal the truth to the
populace later on historia attends a
ceremony in honor of the survey corps as
the queen she awards hanji with a bolo
tie and the surviving soldiers with
medals while giving a medal to aaron her
royal blood triggers a memory within him
after realizing something was wrong she
asked about him concernedly historia
attends a meeting discussing whether the
walls should cooperate with the
anti-marlin volunteers during the
meeting aaron admits that he is capable
of using the full powers of the founding
titan if he touches a royal-blooded
titan historia seems surprised when
aaron states that he did not speak of
the sooner out of concern that she may
have been turned into a titan when the
first his ambassadors arrive on paradise
historia listens to kyomi azumabito go
over the three processes that must take
place to secure the island's safety the
first of them requires the story to
inherit the beast titan from zeke yeager
who has less than a year left to live
the second involves his boosting the
level of technology on paradise the
third is that historia must have as many
children as possible during the 13 years
she has as the beast titan so that there
will be more royal blooded children to
inherit a titan and protect the island
for the 50 years it will take for
paradise to catch up with the rest of
the world historia agrees to the plan as
long as it continues to be necessary
some time later aaron meets astoria
privately at her farm to warn her that
the military police are planning to feed
zeke to her once he arrives on paradise
despite aaron's suggestion that she
either flee or resist historia tells him
that she will accept whatever plan is
deemed necessary to preserve paradise to
historia's distress aaron reveals that
he will use the founding titan to wipe
out the outside world she tries to
remind him that there are many innocents
beyond the walls but aaron is resolute
in his decision historio tells him that
she will not be able to live with
herself if she does not do everything in
her power to stop him aaron then offers
to manipulate her memories using the
founding dieting's power to which
historia replies by asking him about the
possibility of her having a child one mp
believes that this development was
influenced by elena while speculating
that his story is out of wedlock
pregnancy with a local who bullied her
as a child was to delay her from
inheriting the beast titan from zeke
yeager after he reached paradise island
after a rebellious faction emerges
commander pixas orders the military to
rescue historia since she is a potential
target during the onslaught of the
rumbling historia goes into labor aaron
is eventually killed and the rumbling is
stopped by the combined efforts of the
survey corps and the warriors over the
next three years historia gets married
to her child's father and begins
entering peace talks with the outside
world in the year 857 the outside world
dispatches a group of ambassadors to
paradise to begin peace talks she sends
a letter to the ambassadors explaining
that the jaegers on the island have
raised an army in the three years since
aaron's death to prepare for any attacks
from the outside world thank you so much
for watching this video it really means
a lot to us we will see you guys very
soon in one of our next videos